This dollar bill has a DISEASE.
It might seem healthy, but if you look real
close, you’ll see a virus that is slowly
but surely eating away it’s purchasing power
every day.
This particular virus is named inflation,
and every dollar in your bank account is infected with it.
If you’ve ever taken a high school economics
class, you’ve probably already heard the term.
But most of us only know that it’s the reason
one day we’ll tell our grandkids “Back
in my day, Macbook Pro’s only cost one bitcoin”!
But inflation isn’t just some benign force.
It’s why getting a raise is so important, why the
cost of education is spiraling out of control
and in extreme examples, it’s affecting
millions of people’s ability to put food
on the table.
And it’s something you need to learn how
to live alongside without letting it sideline
your financial goals!
Now, inflation wouldn’t be such a big deal
if everything inflated at the exact same rate.
Who cares if housing prices skyrocketed if
your salary instantly compensated to match.
The problem arises because different things
inflate at different rates and sometimes for
completely different reasons.
There are two main types.
The first is cost-push inflation.
This is when companies are forced to raise
prices because the cost of the materials to
make the thing or provide the service has
gone up.
For example, did you happen to notice how
vanilla ice cream is getting more expensive?
Madagascar, the world’s largest supplier,
has been consistently hit with terrible storms
that have been destroying the delicate crop.
So if the companies relying on vanilla want
to keep their profit margins the same, they
will have to consider pushing that increased
cost onto their customers in the form of a
higher price.
Which they can get away with to a certain
point, assuming the economy is healthy enough
for it to not affect demand too dramatically.
Then there’s demand-pull inflation.
Take our hometown Austin.
It’s a rapidly growing city but the supply
of housing hasn’t been able to match the
demand.
Meaning landlords and people selling their
homes are in the position to ask for higher
prices than they did the year before.
While both of these examples aren’t super
fun on our wallet, inflation is in many scenarios
related to growth.
When an economy is growing, the overall demand
for goods goes up.
Conversely, when the economy isn’t going
well inflation tends to decrease because there’s
not enough demand to support a price increase.
But, like a virus, if inflation is allowed
to run rampant, really really bad things can happen.
Take Venezuela.
Corruption combined with economic mismanagement
and an authoritarian government has led to
a humanitarian crisis of epic proportions.
The hyperinflation is so bad that the government
refuses to share any official numbers, so
Bloomberg created “the Cafe Con Leche index”
measuring the price of a cup of coffee in
eastern Caracas.
In March of 2018 that cup of coffee cost 1.2
Bolivars and just one year later, that same
cup cost 2,800 bolivars.
It’s no wonder that at nearly a third of
the population has left the country.
So, whose job is it to make sure that doesn’t
happen?
Here in the US it’s the Federal Reserve.
The Fed, is the bank of banks and its job
is essentially to walk a tightrope between
encouraging the economy to grow, aka, allowing
prices to rise, but at the same time, keeping
inflation from gaining too much ground and
taking away the purchasing power of its citizens.
The Fed tries to fight inflation in three
different ways: Setting the interest rate
that banks borrow money from them, adjusting
how much cash banks are required to have on
hand, and deciding how much new money can
be printed.
These methods control how much money is floating
around the economy.
The more money floating around, the more liberal
banks feel about lending it out, so interest
rates go down.
Which means it’s easier for people like
you and me to get a mortgage, a credit card,
a student or small business loan, and the
economy grows.
But if it grows too fast, prices will go up
faster than wages can keep pace—and your
savings are suddenly worth a lot less.
That money you set aside for a Hawaiian vacation
will now only get you as far as San Antonio.
There’s no question that regulating inflation
on macro-economic level is massively complicated.
Thankfully, Unless you’re current Federal
Reserve Chairman Jerome Powell, you don’t
have any control over it.
But on the micro-economic level it’s your
job to inoculate yourself.
And guess what, there’s only one vaccine
out there, investing.
Most people know they should invest…but
why?
Why can’t you simply save your way into
wealth?
I think it’s time to…
Run the numbers!
This is Tricia.
She feels sort of scared of the stock market
and travels a lot so she doesn’t feel like
owning real estate for the foreseeable future.
What if she wanted to try and save money into
a checking account to get to her personal
retirement goal of 850,000 dollars?
If inflation didn’t exist, it would be pretty
simple algebra.
If she started saving at 30 and wanted to
retire at 65 that would require her to save
$2,023 per month in order to hit her nest
egg goal.
A challenging number to hit even for higher
earners.
But the reality with inflation is way worse.
The Fed’s goal is to keep inflation at around
2 percent per year.
So let’s say that actually happens.
That means in order to keep the same purchasing
power of 850,000 in the future, her new goal
will have to be adjusted to almost 1.7 million
dollars.
That would require her to set aside double
the money or the equivalent of $4,047 per month.
Yikes!
But if Tricia decided to educate herself a
bit and move past her investing fears, she
could harness the same forces that created
the inflation in the first place to her benefit.
If she decided to invest her way to retirement
through some stock-based mutual funds with
an average return of 8% per year, she could
still hit that 1.6 million dollar goal, by
only saving $822/month.
Ok, while that’s not chump change, that
sounds WAY more realistic than four grand
a month!
It’s also important for Tricia to keep a
close eye on her income.
If it doesn’t increase to keep pace with
inflation, she’s essentially making less
money every year, even if her salary stays
the same.
So instead of seeing inflation as an evil
virus, let’s think of it like another invisible
powerful force, the wind.
You can choose to work against it or hoist
a sail and let the forces at play work on
your behalf.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description if you'd like to support us on Patreon.
Have you noticed the effect of inflation in
your life?
Tell us about it in the comments.